thanks for that child struck by
tragedies lost balloons cliche so what
exactly led castor Troy to plant Sean
archers murder here of all places
he plotted this and said yep carousel
that's where I'll get this bastard also
villain that the movie will go on to
portray is 100% gleefully psycho crazy
shows remorse at the death of his
enemies child also he does not fire
again to ensure his original intended
target is dead even John was not above
the pan over awards display on the wall
to show heroes amazing worthiness cliche
FBI profile misspells Nicolas Cage
arbitrary 11 day countdown is arbitrary
either that or castor Troy gave himself
the biggest head start to get away from
a bomb in the history of head starts yep
Matt's Nicolas Cage alright jet was just
charted Anderson air view guess who paid
the bill in cash Pollux Troy so they're
named castor and pollux astronomy fan
parents are astronomy fans also how is
there an instant record of Pollux Troy
renting an aircraft if he paid cash and
if he's paying cash why is he using his
real name instead of doing it under
Seymour butts or some you know odd page
for hours
rageh Lingus tongue sucking but you
sucked his tongue how was the plan not
for you to shoot him in the shoulder and
arrest him before this plane could even
approach take off my ass Archer a mile
head of Troy on the runway and everyone
else is behind him he'll and the time it
took to get ahead of his plane he could
have arrested Troy already it's all
because they want Archer to play chicken
with the plane later isn't also when all
this started he was only this far away
from the plane now he's at Fast &
Furious 6 runway distance castor Troy is
standing in the airplane when it wrecks
into this hangar and his body suffered
to no consequences there was quite a bit
of who gives a sh ton play in the scene
edited with leftover shots where they
accidentally turned the camera on and
rolled for one second before turning it
off you can totally see the wire on this
guy in the shot which will be used to
make him fly backwards in this show I'm
beginning to think these two or nemec's
only because of neutral terrible aim
neither of these two shoots right now
thus ending the standoff
both guns at point-blank Skol range
first one that pulls the trigger wins
right instead okay
policeman don't shoot me in what will
become the movies protocol in several
scenes Sean decides not to back up a
respectful distance which means Troy can
pull a knife on it with the pure heat of
a jet engine like this not melt or kill
a dude I'm asking here
jet engine heat index expert but seems
to my layman's eye that this asshole
should be dead as Sean's huge news about
bagging the man who killed their son
waited until he got home to spring it on
her the FBI file on Shawn's kid is
titled carousel sniper victim like you
would if there was a serial killer out
there named the carousel sniper if
you're going to be oddly cold about a
fellow FBI agent son's death why isn't
this titled castor Troy murder victim
number 29 carousel Follies are some
where's puck straw future human
resources call I know right but brace
yourself that's not even the stupidest
idea they've got turnips CCH pounder is
addictive turnips what if you can walk
into air one prison and give Pollux a
nice big brotherly hug as castor Troy or
think about this for a second put Casper
Troy's picture in the news and ask if
anyone saw this guy around town acting
weird the other day and see if 100 choir
members remember the priest who grabbed
that one chicks ass and then search the
convention center I know it's a little
bit out there but it just might work I
know he did you don't know what I can do
please say truth serum and not changing
someone's physical appearance to trick
people to talk also does Archer himself
have to be the guy who gets thrown into
Pollock's his cell can't this be some
low-level Leonardo DiCaprio from
departed kinda guy who has no family and
maybe took an acting class blood types
won't match befall at your height weight
and head shape will for some reason and
your hands arms posture style walking
height difference is negligible
according to Wikipedia it's two inches a
brother would definitely notice a sudden
two-inch change in his siblings height
you have lived and breathed castor Troy
for years yeah but it's not like you've
been hanging out with him or anything
your brief moments trying to apprehend
him doesn't mean you're an acting expert
on all things castor Troy is a black-bag
operation strictly off the books
how does she plan to explain to the FBI
boss why they kept Troy alive and he's
now entering prison I'll do it he'll do
it rebellious teenage daughter keeps her
door open because that's what teenagers
do dad drapes the covers over his kid to
show that he cares cliche doctor um if
he does half of what he says he can do
you'll be instantly shanked for not
looking like castor Troy at all I mean
seriously isn't evacuating LA a better
alternative than this are you giving the
haircut in the surgery room with the no
face patient is that even sanitary and
here's where I remind the movie it told
me their blood types were different that
makes all other transplants impossible
so the same is for the movie even
mentioning it
since they could have just easily made
these two have the same blood type of
course then I'd have send the movie for
convenience so how is there absolutely
no scarring where they cut his face even
with makeup or flesh colored face caulk
that's got to be the most unbelievable
thing about this I can't believe I just
said that six days until the 18th and
yeah the bomb clock shows they have nine
days until the bomb goes off because
math is inconvenient face searches well
here let me massage your itch is out
archers gonna be pissed when he comes
back from his training up and finds out
the guy's knee-deep in Georgia swamp
these guys must have heard that the
helipad was in dire need of clunky
exposition also the cover story is a
training out whether he's learning or
teaching there was no fucking way an
agent that just nearly died apprehending
the world's most wanted criminal would
be sung on a training off this entire
prisons one big magnetic field what
doesn't that with electronics and
pacemakers and everything metal like the
lights or tables or architectural
support beams or the guns the guards are
holding because if you'll accept that
John Travolta can become Nicolas Cage
through surgery
then you'll accepting anything Hey look
they found a way to show Lucy in this
prison castor Troy biggest criminal
psychopath murderer in all of ever is
put in general population is getting
thrown when they have magnetic boots on
and getting on tables and jumping on
people this is a fling magnetic field
assholes archers face miraculously stays
on during this fight this highly
experimental facility is keeping a known
criminal psychopath and no one is here
to guard it and they didn't even put
restraints on the guy just in case
something like this might happen so
Castro's henchmen believed the guy on
the other end of the line was actually
him somehow found Walsh and kidnapped
him and brought him here without
thinking this is a setup aren't they
giving you your medication what was my
medication come on this dude has no
reason to suspect face transplant
surgery as possible nor any reason to
think this is anyone other than his
brother after a long coma
Jesus do you do not taunt your foe
before your plan to defeat said foe is
complete and definitely not before
you've actually gotten out of prison
Archer is the greatest agent alive and
he's a complete dumbass sounds about
right
oh yeah did they also swap eyeballs okay
so turning John Travolta into Nicolas
Cage I can kinda sorta buy in that
suspend my disbelief in a science
fiction movie stored away during cage in
Travolta has got to be a trickier
process especially in a fly-by-night
under duress with no planning sort of
way I'd like to know how Troy tracked
down these people and somehow knew that
they were the only ones that knew the
secret about Sean maybe Walsh told it
but they'd either have to set a trap for
them so that they drive out to the
Institute in the middle of
night or they'd have to find their
addresses and kidnap trained FBI agents
the only way Castro knows which houses
Shawn's is because Eve just happens to
be walking outside right now do you mean
he didn't get a simple address with her
dad acting like Bob from Alabama on To
Catch a Predator she doesn't feel the
need to put any pants on or is in any
way I think like a teenage girl would in
this situation what about our
$10,000,000 what about when I become an
American Hero for defusing the bomb well
you'll be a hero who does not have 10
million but whatever I trust your evil
plan instincts here the little flamey
things show up before castor even
presses the buttons
oh sure this giant prison TV that has
only been showing soothing nature and
wildlife footage suddenly switches to
news just so Shawn can see the news that
will infuriate him the meal looks nice
all but none of these dishes are on
warmers meaning cold and rubbery is the
order of the day also lobster spaghetti
salad and giant asparagus tips are some
that ladies and gentlemen is a meal
thrown together by a truly clueless
person Jesus how many candles did castor
have to light for this book in fire
hazard dinners John and Joan bone by the
way dude Shawn and castor have the same
penis size Sean is allowed to do this
why why would you light the cigarette of
a prisoner ever especially one who's
about to get electric shocks
dubov I didn't touch your wife I didn't
touch your sister thankfully for our
hero this asshole was totally cognizant
thirty seconds after having its brain
electrified but I know your wife loves
you he's waiting for you
so let's get out of here Shawn just
learned of this place and had no idea
dubab was getting electric shocks but he
is crucial to the entire plan to get out
of here and not only that he's able to
get dubab to forgive caster and help him
here with mere words oh I mean yeah this
seems like a perfectly sound plan why
would you agree to do this even if you
get out of this room you're gonna have a
hard time getting through the next one
not to mention what happens on the
outside this guy fires all the bullets
into the corner and somehow still
doesn't hit his target haha this prison
has a bat of sulfuric acid just lying
around waiting for its day in the Sun
when did this asshole get up here
weren't there guards up here just a
second ago thankfully Archer knows this
prison computer operating system inside
and out and now we're saving people from
falling by grabbing the business end of
a gun as they grab the barrel he does
eventually die however and that makes me
happy more pointless helicopter aiming
gives all cops in all movies that
combined perfect zero point zero
casualty score Terminator 2 would be
proud helicopter sees him go in the
water and figure zapped you can't swim
anyway right so drop everything you're
doing to go into that call by all means
take Jamie go to your mother's don't
tell them where you're going just go
whoever you are don't call again first
off even if you don't believe this both
story you know Sean's been different
lately and it's weirded you out second
off why not ask some questions you're
not the least bit curious
Deitrick doesn't express any concern
that escaped felon castor Troy is
standing in his apartment when he is a
known associate I'd like to take his his
face
wrong-o credits his face okay guys we
get it face hey guys we're officially at
the filmed in Panavision and picture
number three four nine five form the
Motion Picture Association of America at
this point we're about to see the no
animal was harmed in the making of this
film message we've rolled some goddamn
credits bitches filmmakers thought they
were going to need movie tricks to
capture this Nicolas Cage on drugs
sequence but quickly realized cage could
blur on cue but what I'm trying to tell
you brother Pollux in a super loud voice
inside the archer residence as though no
one would ever hear me dumbass boyfriend
tries to rape Jamie in the driveway of a
badass FBI agent and he just happens to
pull this on a night where sean is
actually caster and Castro can save her
to prove how good he is just before Eve
starts questioning his identity you
remind me of my dead son cliche why
didn't the real caster call and warn his
most trusted henchman about the face
whopping so they could apprehend or
shoot Archer on site instead of having
to basically die here in the scene to
keep up the charade
cool I know he's in a confused State and
seeing a little kid that reminds him of
Michael is emotional but damn this is a
less than a mature mistake by Sean why
is this guy by himself crashing through
the ceiling window and the motherfucker
is so slow he's basically saying go
ahead and shoot my ass this is some easy
the scene gets a lot of deserved credit
for putting slow-motion action against a
soothing rendition of somewhere over the
rainbow but from an editing standpoint
it's just a series of shots of
characters I'm mildly recognized that
ultimately makes no sense also he cannot
possibly have headphones that are this
good the drone auto the gunfire were the
psychological damage put the boy down
FBI guy follows page five of the FBI guy
movie manual which states to hold the
gun as close as possible to your target
because nothing ever went wrong using
that technique don't ever want to see
you do that we supposed to be rooting
for the criminal girlfriend of counselor
troi at this point because she spawned a
kid I don't know what I hate wearing
worse your face or your body well you're
only wearing his face and you each kept
your own bodies so obviously the answer
is his face why doesn't one of them just
go ahead and shoot the other right now
have they not done this showdown enough
already
let's just kill each other well I've got
a knockoff ass in for this awesomeness
here carry on if you hear the gunshot at
this range can you actually dodge it he
survives running out of this explosion
like he's the fucking Starship
Enterprise
sir why so upset it's just Paul extroyer
I cast her hopes to continue the charade
he better hope the ballistics on this
murder don't come back to his gun caster
is about to kill Victor in a room where
the blinds are still open and
considering the fact that he's a
national hero and is on the cover of
Time you think at least one person in
the office would be looking this way but
no everyone Minds their business call
paramedics Vic Euler's ours had a heart
attack and tell the paramedics not to
pay any attention to the bruises and
marks on his neck and skull from where I
just punch the shit out of it yes I
could enter a federal prison as castor
Troy Sean Archer not to mention the
screenwriter would be excellent at
cinemasins
I don't know why Sean is trying to
explain the impossible to believe plot a
face-off instead of just saying a bunch
of stuff only he would know to prove
that he's actually Sean dude that's your
dead son your husband mee-mah Sean's
blood type is o-negative Castor's is a B
oh so the blood types are different just
for this silly mechanism for proving his
story to Eve good thing she just happens
to be a doctor I know I can act
I know my hands look completely
different with more puns around the tips
and Knuckles Oh would make me wake up
for sure
damn but he's merely rounds for a moment
and drifts back off like oh let's dip in
the B or whatever Wow Dan dude we know
you're right do you have to be a creepy
stalker I once took a date out for surf
and turf now that we've had enough
mistrust and drama Shawn finally tells a
story he should have back at the house a
minute ago and he he was so drunk he
fixed the wrong tooth why we allowed a
stinking drunk to poke around in your
mouth is beyond me
but I think it was fired the next day
and his family left it anyway back to
our everlasting tale of woe you know
what but he went to the hospital and I
need to check up on her for some reason
just a nagging feeling I have so Eve got
a sample of caster's blood just before
she went to bed and it was clearly still
nighttime when she went to the hospital
but then caster wakes up it's morning
and Eve and Shawn are still at the
hospital
that story about the crazy drunk dentist
must have taken eight hours to tell also
now that it's morning in the hospital is
buzzing with activity
it's amazing not one person has come to
check in on Eve and her mystery patient
and discover cast around the open I know
Shawn's wife is always behind the
curtains on this floor of the hospital I
don't need to ask anyone where she is
her life as a doctor is insanely
predictable because he believes you
should be aware of his presence to take
out the element of surprise for some
reason also that guy looked a lot like
the guy I saw on TV who escaped prison
but couldn't be that guy he's a
convicted felon so why will he show up
to a church why is the entire dumb
population of California in this church
that's pretty unsanitary and I'm not
sitting on one of those pews shouldn't
he just shoot him in the back right now
instead of walking slowly to a showdown
that leads to a boat chase that leads to
a fistfight yes religious just in case
you didn't know caster was doing - Jesus
Christ pose here's an example of Jesus
doing the Jesus Christ pose this is
truly the worst plan I've ever seen when
it comes to setting up a duel with your
hated enemy was this even necessary why
put yourself at this much risk and now
you see even more reason why he
shouldn't have alerted caster to his
presence and I'd ask how he managed to
find the daughter so quickly but knowing
her she was hiding in her bedroom
smoking cigarettes and her panties no
father could know brother could either
could his sister did she come from and
did she just hear that exchange between
castor and Sean why is she not as
confused as me right now gunned down why
don't you put your guns down
John whoo sees your Reservoir Dogs and
Reese's you uh Vincent Vega coming out
of the bathroom in Pulp Fiction it's a
string bit but one Hollywood allows hey
we definitely only need to see gun
shooting flower vases getting destroyed
and doves flying in this scene
definitely not who's shooting at who and
where everybody is that's crazy talk how
is anyone going to get called out to the
scene here they're on beachfront
property so you know somebody's heard
gunshots and I realize she's confused
but she clearly saw her father shooting
at her a few seconds ago right why does
she go all in on that man side right now
honey don't listen to him on E he's not
your father hear my voice how is he
suddenly able to bypass the voice
modulator is that Shawn doing a spot-on
impersonation of himself of course no
matter what situation you find yourself
in it's always a good time to show your
rapey tendencies because that's how
teenagers talk you see thankfully here
is a second speed boat on this beer that
is not tied up or anything Andy also
it's almost like the filmmaker said you
know what show down at the church isn't
good enough let's have a speedboat
action scene after that the stunt
doubles in these overhead shots are
cooking hilariously have asked black
suit black hair you'll do get in there
best he could do a second ago was hit
the fuel line of the boat next to him
and not the driver but now sheriff he
Deadshot's all the cops on this boat I
like a good boat ramp jump as much as
the next guy but what's the entire back
of the police boat made of extra
flammable materials how does fiberglass
striking fiberglass create grenade level
explosions also boat going through an
exploding boat somehow dodges the
explosion
this is Schrodinger's cat only in this
case we're observing the boat both alive
and dead at the same time instead of
just wondering physics speedboat was
made up of 95% nitroglycerin and a meth
lab well that clearly wasn't enough
action let's have a fist fight now they
probably cut the five other endings this
movie had in the script because that was
overkill this is walking really close to
the person you're about to kill thing is
infuriating he's scouring up the droll
two-face so Archer won't be able to use
it but he's apparently forgotten how
freaky fast the scar healing technology
is at the face transplant lab which can
easily undo this nonsense done hey let's
put John in the exact same ambulance we
put castor that's protocol right when
you wake up everything
just the way it was those farts at the
Walsh Institute weren't the only
dickheads who could do faceoff surgery
I'm glad Walsh is dead that prick why
wasn't Eve at the hospital waiting for
him when the surgery was over this
procedure is so safe and uninvaded it's
like going to the dentist you know one
who's not drunk well he even somehow
grew his hair back out we grafted his
hairline amazing Jesus he had time to
recover from surgery and go through with
an adoption and bring the kid home on
that very day - damn what did Jamie say
earlier also this means Adam and Eve are
going to live in the same house again
pray for humanity hi now I never have to
mourn my brother Michael I'd like to
take his his face off
[Music]
his face face these these civilized
people they'll eat each other how did I
spend that much money yeah I know it's
sexy Woodhouse that's why I bought ten
mirror
[Music]
you understand that the nerves were
completely severed mr. Napier football
practice look I given a million ladies a
million foot massages
and they all meant something we act like
they don't but they do and that's what's
so cool about
[Music]
how can I get out of here
you can't how in the name of Zeus's
butthole
did you get out of yourself ears no my
hand here smell my hand no you smell my
picture
smell my hand hey kid smell my hand
smell my hand
EEP why didn't you just open with this
move in the beginning I'm sorry I shot
you
oh honey just smell my hand my name is
Jamie in this family we smell hands
welcome and smell my hair